Okay, welcome everybody to another, somebody saying they can't hear me.
Can you hear me yet? Make sure you turn your speaker on.
No sound.
Okay.
Oh, some people are saying they can hear me fine.
So somebody can hear me and somebody can't that it has to be your sound, your speaker.
So please check your speaker, turn up your volume on your computer many times. That's the problem.
And we will keep rolling and this will be recorded so you can listen to it later.
If you still can't figure out your volume.
Of course, you can't even hear me if you can't figure out your volume. So what am I talking about?
All right, so.
All right, so couple housekeeping things that I say and raise a call.
Make sure you look for questions in our website and our blog.
You can search this little thing on our website.
And then you can search for questions you don't have to wait till the zoom call.
But how you have this wonderful patient membership site.
We've been waiting a long time to finish this and get this done.
Dustin and myself have worked well and hard to do this.
So hope everybody appreciates it.
And more than that, even if you don't appreciate it, hope you use it.
So this is where you need to submit your questions.
So if you have not been on the patient membership site.
Search your email for search your email.
The email that yours your made email that you use to start with us.
That was on your intake form that you gave us as your made email.
And search for either info at cutters clinic.com because that's where you're.
Welcome letter your email should have come from last Thursday.
We launched this last Thursday.
At noon.
This site was launched and every one of you should have gotten an email from info and cutters clinic.com.
Say welcome to cutters clinic patient membership site.
And this is how you log in to you log in via that email that you gave us.
And then you create your own password.
So if you haven't done that, please do that.
You can also search for membership and look for cutters clinic.
Because you should see it there.
So we do still have been receiving some questions via an email to cutters clinic or my email.
That shouldn't happen anymore.
Your questions should come through our patient membership site.
There is a form at the bottom of nearly every page where submit your zoom call questions.
And on the zoom call question page.
See right here.
Zoom calls.
We'll take on that.
So there's multiple pages in this site.
It is literally a brand new website.
And it's got things on there that are only available to our patients.
So please, I spent a lot of time putting the information together.
A lot of your questions that you ask may already be answered on a short little video on that site.
So look for that.
That's where all these zoom call recordings will be placed as well.
You could see last week's zoom call on this site.
So they'll always be uploaded and put out here for future use.
So if you can't find that.
And go to this. If you search for this and you still don't see an invite.
And email athletics and I don't I can't find my invite.
And we can resend it to you.
So please look for that.
All right, let's get to your questions.
I'm on a medication.
And do I need to take the medicine several hours away from the right.
It doesn't make a difference what medication it is.
Do you can you not take your medication while you're using the right.
The answer is no that makes no difference whatsoever.
Well, there's a question.
Maybe they're thinking, should I not do the eye on Broadway right after I take my medication?
Will it pull the medication out of my body?
There's no evidence that either.
So you don't have to worry about timing with right for use.
We don't have to worry about timing with a pro-way of use.
As far as use of any medication, there should be no interference with that.
How often do I need to do coffee enemies?
Well, that depends on you.
You should ask your liaison that person. I don't ask this question.
So typically we recommend coffee enemies daily.
Some people can't do them daily because they have rectal cancer.
They don't do them at all. So everybody's a little bit weak with that.
Personally, I don't do coffee enemies at all.
I shouldn't say that because I did one last couple of weeks ago.
But it's, but I don't do them regularly anymore.
So.
That's just for me, that's myself and tidy and busyness of life.
So I don't do them on a regular basis.
It doesn't mean you can't do them on a regular basis.
So if a person's in a lot of pain, they have a lot of inflammation,
or they have any adema build up in their gut or their lungs,
that it's typically recommended that you do more than one coffee enemy day.
We've had people do five coffee enemies a day.
Well, what's the purpose of that? I'm not constipated.
Go back to understand what the purpose of a coffee enemy is.
The purpose of the coffee enemy is to stimulate your parasympathetics.
And by stimulating the parasympathetics, you help walk pain pathways as well.
So by doing coffee enemies, you can help mitigate pain.
And again, you could do a very simplified version of a coffee enemy.
Oh, there's no way I could lay down on my side and do a coffee enemy the way it's recommended.
I can't, it's hard for me to get up. That causes more pain.
You could go do a coffee enemy standing in the shower, hold it for two, three minutes,
and then go void.
That's still going to stimulate your parasympathetics.
So you can get created with these things.
So I talked to some of the other day that while making the coffee in the pot,
the way it's recommended on your videos is that's just, oh my gosh,
it's just hard for me. I live alone.
Put a sakes, get some organic coffee, brew it in your coffee maker,
and then cool it with water and use that.
Do any form of coffee enemy like this is going to be beneficial.
It doesn't have to be don't get hung up on what's perfect.
And, and then not do it because of that reason.
I'm wondering if Dr. Cutters is able to send orders for blood transfusion.
No, we can't do that. So we can't send orders for blood transfusion.
We can't send orders for a CT scan or an MRI or even an ultrasound.
You're going to have to get that from a primary position.
I'm thankful for more energy and stamina following my chronicle and seed results,
bladder cancer is hard to status, but today I feel well,
and I know the age of the Lord and camps around me. Amen.
God is using the story he has given me in cancer to speak of his goodwill.
Still praying for your Dr. Cutters. Thank you.
Enjoy the Lord's rest today. Praise God.
Well, God is good.
Always, even if we're not doing better, even if I'm getting sicker,
even if I might pass away from this cancer, it doesn't change the goodness
and the greatness of God in my life.
I trust in his sovereignty in all things.
And, and praise God for that.
I'm trying to be proactive with having undervaxed friends with my blood type
to donate blood for me in case I need a transfusion.
What idea? There's a lot of vaccinated people on here trying to insult you,
and I know this person has no idea that they're not trying to insult anybody either,
but the vaccine itself, and we were talking about the COVID vaccine,
has factors in it that I personally would want to put into my veins.
So I contacted Memorial Blood Bank today. This can be done.
So this is good information. So I put it up here.
Takes about seven business days for the time of donation to be available to me.
First step, I need ordering Dr. to fill out this form and this page.
So you can utilize this form if you need to receive blood.
And you want people to donate blood for you so that can be stored for you.
Great information. Thank you to the person who submitted this.
This can be beneficial to a lot of people.
Next question. Some of that's your past. Dr. Morris for one suggests that the kidney should be filtering.
So urine appears cloudy or has particulates in it.
That this is an indication that the lib kidney materials are working correctly.
I understand that if you're not showing sentiment in your urine,
you are not getting rid of acidic waste.
And your lib system is not working optimally.
That I really don't understand this process or whether the kidney is filtering is truly necessary.
Could you please talk about this subject?
Yeah, so I would not agree with this comment whatsoever.
But when you do a u a urine analysis, that's one of the things that the test trick is looking for is sediment or cloudy urine.
That's a sign of possible infection and some other things.
So it certainly is not a sign of acidic waste better, better a fact.
Typically cloudy or sediment in your urine is going to be calcium particulates, which is going to cause the urine to be more alkaline, not acidic.
So I'm not sure where this is coming from for a physiological standpoint.
Your kidneys are an essential part of your detoxification process.
So the major organ of detoxification with your liver, your ball bladder, your large intestine and your skin.
So it is necessary for them to be working, but I wouldn't be concerned about whether they're sent in the urine or not.
Like to be wrong, I'm just telling you my opinion.
With colon cancer following by Connors Clinic protocol, how do we determine progress as we made that is what testing it is there a suggested interval months to three months, etc.
Certainly there is the option of CT scans MRIs and maybe even a scope inspection of the colon.
What do clients do to arrange those, do they unless they're a collegeist?
Has it asked my colleges to do those things, especially that participating in their recommended therapy?
Good question.
So this is a video that I actually created on our membership site.
So on our membership site, you go to that, you can look at how do I know I'm getting better video and you can read.
I'm going to do a video and help understand that.
But in short, yes, the best way to know whether your cancer is improving or not is to compare apples to apples if you have a CT scan that measures a tumor of 4.5 centimeters round.
So if you have a CT scan, best done by that same hospital or clinic, measured that in a comparative study would be the best way to compare whether my cancer is getting better or not.
But most of my patients don't want to keep doing CT scans.
That's a lot of radiation.
So I'm going to keep doing that.
Is there another way to test?
Well, that's where you go to that video and the membership site.
You can use tumor markers, some cancers don't show to the workers. What am I supposed to do?
Well, we used to have the demoral test. Well, that is being backed up and some people have said that they're not even accepting tests right now because cancer is literally going like wildfire around the world.
They're backed up and they can't even accept any more tests. Well, we used to have the IV gene, but during COVID, they ended up getting they ended up closing because they didn't have enough business.
So it is difficult to know how to measure progress sometimes.
This is why I tell people it's best not to burn your bridges with your oncologist, just kindly say, can I get back to you when I want to start something.
I just don't want to start something right now. Would you help me with testing as I try to do some things on my own if they say no, it's my way or the highway.
To find another oncologist, they're all over the place. Go to somebody else and say, hey, you know, this guy just booted me because I wouldn't do his protocol. I'm trying to pray about my situation and make a decision as best for me.
I just want somebody to monitor it nine times at a time. You're going to find the next person go, oh, we'll take care of you. We're not in my way or the highway place. We want to just support you and serve you thinking, you know, that they that's really their desire or thinking that, hey, if they use us to the road, that is great. So that's my suggestion. So yes, there is no.
You know magic bullets out there of testing that you can measure progress with your we are we there's this limited technology that exists today.
Unfortunately, hopefully at some time in the future that will change.
But the Navarro test on standby and no options for IVG test, note by C, C, A, that's the markers are in normal rage, not sure of a cancer marker test worth doing.
So yeah, it becomes difficult like I said, there are you can do the CA 125 possibly with with colon cancer.
And even had some colon cancer show up at 2729, but that's more rare. You could look at other markers to other inflammatory markers, possibly.
But yeah, it was nothing that's going to be perfect. And quite honestly, even the gold standard CT scans is then perfect.
So you can get false positive growths and false positive shrinkages usually not that but usually false positive growths are called pseudo pseudo growths that are not beneficial at all to see.
So yeah, that's something that is just difficult to deal with.
Trust me, I don't want yet another supplement, but I'm curious about the iron, I'm taking for anemia since cancer likes tired and wondering about artimistic in my particular case.
So yeah, typically what a person is taking iron, we recommend taking an artimistic in with it.
Artimistic it has been found to follow higher and artimistic can be a cancer killer, especially the inside of a cancer cell.
But so can some other things too. So don't sell that short.
Maybe it's best just to take your iron with your other supplements so that it can follow other things can take along with.
Research on everything else where we just don't know what could possibly take what could possibly happen.
So maybe try taking it just with your other supplements and not add an artimistic at this point in time, certainly you can, but again, I would favor of less this more.
So what's the difference between Iverbectin and fed bed is all tested well for a bed is all does that mean Iverbectin would be good to take with it or in replacement of it.
Or should I just stop taking Iverbectin and just take the iron fed bed is all I'd say the last thing we should just stop taking the Iverbectin unless you feel like that is helping to.
So they're totally different drugs so they're they're very different so you can't switch about so there's not a flip flop.
They can both be helpful their studies on the Iverbectin with cancer.
But before they thought anybody use it, but they're not interchangeable.
Not an old test that's an organic acid test results.
For Evan, he has high oxalates.
We are reducing them it is diet giving magnesium citrate.
So magnesium citrate can help to oxalates in the gut.
So it's really good if you're constipated to so and using Epsom salt baths.
I will add calcium citrate because calcium citrate can buy oxalates in the gut as well.
When I have his constipation under control, I wanted to check to see if bad.
It's our great anti-inflammatory mix or too narrow clear would be high in oxalates. I'd say no. So continue to take those.
The hair analysis back for doctors data and using any cutlers, county rules and he covers really an expert he was really an expert in heavy metal detox and such.
Not as essential elements he meets one rule. There is low mercury in the toxic elements.
I experienced that is only from fish and he only eats salmon on occasion.
It isn't the worst hair test I've ever seen, but it indicates some mercury toxicity is a dangerous to dress at this point.
Will that be necessary at some point.
So the real question is when you're dealing with cancer and you have a toxicity that you know you have.
I know I have this with dental issues. Hey, I know I have toxic teeth that I want to deal with the mercury and my mercury fillings that I want to get out.
Should I get those out right now.
If you slow down, wait until we get things balanced out and then we can deal with purposefully deep fully you know mercury out of your teeth through a through a biological dentist.
You don't want to spill too many toxins and you can do that.
You're using key laders strong key laders. You don't want to do that, especially when you're dealing with cancer, because that could cause a inflammatory reaction, especially with brain cancer.
So I would say wait on those things.
Remember to go back to the website and download the seven phases of detoxification, because that will explain to you that.
Though yes, you might do a specific key lation for a heavy metal or something like that, or if you're going to have the mercury out of your teeth, but detoxification is a process that you're doing constantly and you're supporting those pathways constantly.
It is what I call phase zero of the detoxification phases, the seven phases, where you are actually trying to use a product to key later your grabbing onto something in the tissue pointed out of the body.
You want to make sure you're supporting all those other phases before you're doing that.
And before you get to aggressive doing that at least.
And that you've called out any other inflammation in the body and your you feel like you're healthier and healthier state to be able to do that. So we don't want to hold on.
Last reminder is please mail your cheek swabs to this address. It is on the what it's membership site to so other membership shot site you have the cheek swab download and where you can order cheek swabs from our website.
And it has that address on there too. So if you arrived at this call late on the zoom call, make sure that you get on our membership site.
And again, if I get out your membership site, I don't know I confused I don't remember anything about a membership site search for through your main email search for informed colors clinic.com or search membership in your main email.
And you should see an invite follow that invite the directions create music your user day, but the email that's going to be your early choice create a password and get on our membership site where you can see lots of pages new pages and only members can see a lot of questions answered.
You can get these zoom calls that are recorded and downloaded into that.
Remember to email your cheek swabs back to there again.
Okay, let's jump to some questions that you've said.
There's one comment I have been making my coffee for my coffee and a little concentrate four days worth at a time.
After that, I refrigerate and then I do back to normal to use daily. Do you see any problem with that.
No, that's a great way to do it.
But there are some people that are very ill and not feeling, you know, not feeling well and they just want to do a coffee and then I didn't make it a coffee.
That's where I was talking about earlier about, but it's just brew a cup of coffee and use that.
So try to keep it simple, make it easy so that you could do it so you don't feel like you have to follow all these rules in order to get good results.
Can a drop of frankincense increase white blood cells?
I don't know. I've never seen any data on that.
Should we not take any supplements two hours before and after rife?
No, no, you should be taking.
Again, the right isn't going to repeat on your supplements on your medication.
Your supplements while you're doing the rife, you can eat dinner while you're doing the rife.
You could play chess while you do the rife, you could do an Irish jig while you're doing the rife.
If you can, please send a video of that though, because we'd like to get that up on the membership site, that would be wonderful.
Suggestions for help with hot flashes with ERPR negative and her two positive breast cancer.
So hot flashes have to do a fluctuation of estrogen.
And the first step that I would go to with hot flashes with breast cancer, even if your ERPR negative and her two negative, I would still go to adapt to just so remember that the majority of your estrogen is created by your ovaries.
But your adredals also create some estrogen too.
That's why you, you know, when you go through menopause or if you have a hysterectomy, you still have estrogen.
Well, where's that coming from? It's coming from your adrenal glands.
So if you're having fluctuations of estrogen causing hot flashes, then what you want to do is start with supporting adredals.
So there's adaptogens that I'd recommend.
Ask your.
You're already on adaptions and then ask your liaison, because it might not be that adaptogen using maca.
We use a product called esterolite with some people, but I want to make sure we test it on you.
Because it does have soy price of labels in it, which, which can affect estrogen levels.
For people that are HR, her two positive doesn't that ways of a test, okay, that it's okay to use what we should test that.
Should I discontinue supplements that require food when using the prologue?
No.
So I would just take it with, with your meal with prologue. So when you're doing your soup with the FMD.
So if you don't know what prologue FMD, it's a, it's a fasting mimicky diet product that gives you five days of food.
But it's not much food. So it keeps you under a calorie content that you are.
It mimics fasting in your body without increasing IGF one levels. So it's ideal for cancer patients.
Because if you do a long term fast as a cancer patient, the negative is is that you will raise IGF one levels. Now that's not bad if you don't have cancer.
But if you have cancer, that can not be a good thing.
So if you're going to do a fast more than 24 hours, we recommend doing what's called a fasting mimicky diet company that makes that is company called prologue.
The researcher is forgot his name, but he's out of university of Southern California school that has said brilliant guy heard him speak a couple times.
I've done the prologue FMD multiple times. My staff has done it multiple times. We've had different patients do it. It can be really good. You do not want to even consider this if you're kind of at your perfect weight or a little below.
Because you will probably lose weight on this. But if I could, you know, would hurt me to lose a little weight and I really want to clean myself out to do a fast that the FMD is a great choice for you.
Great for a person who doesn't have cancer, also especially for pre diabetic patients that want to really help control blood sugar and people that have oxidized
LDLs with heart issues. Great product for fasting. You feel like you're pretty hungry, but it's not a five day fast, like a full water fast. You could certainly take your supplements at the time that you eat your soup meals. They're all dehydrated.
We're soupy as per your olives, olives are delicious for your teeny little bar. So yeah. So hopefully everybody has gotten on the patient membership site. We received several of these questions that came in that we talked about from people that jumped on that site and
we used that for them said to their questions and that was great. So we've ever to do that. And we have to get your questions answered as best as possible. And you'll be able to see all those in calls out there. Any other questions.
Later on. Can you explain how IDF1 goes up when fasting? No, that's above my pay grade just done. For about 24 hours of fasting, your IDF1 levels go.
Well, thank you guys all for being on here. Also on the patient membership site. If you guys have ideas for short little videos for me to create.
Please, you know, add it as a question. I might add it to our question in the zoom call, but I'm going to be created some other short video so that you don't have to be waiting for the zoom call for your questions to be answered.
We want this zoom call for your questions to be answered, but we rather have you have your questions answered before waiting for five days for the zoom call.
Like this to be the support group. So we're always here for you. So please utilize that site and give us ideas for improvement in that as well.
And again, for all of you know that I'm praying for you daily and cherish your prayers for us as well.
Well, thank you guys and we will see you next week. Bye bye.